what's going on patronage exits Greg out
ahead and it's John here so we're going
to cover the movies of the week from May
21st through the 28th yeah that's a
week's worth ends right there okay one
thing out of the way Pirates of the
Caribbean to everyone's surprise open up
a number one at the box office
I don't have the numbers and I haven't
compared it there you go
first story of the day right now I don't
need to really talk about that no going
to some actual years they ship me they
watch didn't take it they watched it not
taken and apparently disappointingly
opened according to a box office mojo
report I read the rock ooh yeah leave
that one I feel that way you could have
actually had a story if we wrote down to
note something yeah all the story
there's the rock is not bulletproof on
on both to the box on to is Baywatch to
and then that was that were obviated
then it would have done it was
incredibly well so we're going to cover
some news I want to give a quick mention
we did put down for for a patreon a QA
that we that's it write down any
questions you got a tab a lot of
questions came in John I will film that
this week we're hoping to have it up by
Tuesday or Wednesday for you guys over
on patreon exclusive Q&A segment just
for you folks who pledged to the patreon
community keep calling folks you we love
yeah we do anyway let's hop into this
let's start for the top news story of
the week by far my favorite Tom Halden
is playing young Nathan Drake in sony's
uncharted movie movies being directed by
Shawn Levy who did sounds like Real
Steel not it demeans yeah yeah this is
going to be alright and he produced
stranger things so everyone has a lot of
faith because he's the producer and had
directed a couple episodes a stranger
thing that's always a weird yeah they're
like oh yeah they were involved in the
sample I gather good collaborators but
not just in my numbers for castrating
the entire picture is one thing though
this this story to me is something that
I'm not offended by it by any stretch
because I know there
or there are some fans of the game who
were like this isn't the movie I wonder
because everyone's been dream casting
and their own heads are making you know
videos about who who they think could
play Nathan Drake David Boreanaz if
we're honest you know Tom Hardy Hugh
Jackman Christian Bale the huge I heard
Brad Pitt even at one point he in
summary um I hope you mix Shane be in me
but Tom Holland as young Nathan Drake
you know okay I thought about it a
little bit more since this news was
first announced young Nathan Drake okay
I can be on board with that but did
anyone really want that did anyone want
young Nathan drink this bill yeah the
focus of the a charted movie why can't
they just do a direct video game
adaptation of a damn video yeah so let's
do an assassin's creed movie we'll make
it not based off any one of the many
video games out there let's do it in
charted movie that's going to be all
about young teenage Nathan Drake the
entire time instead that's not what we
wanted the character that's just judging
by the gameplay would not be as
interesting to be yeah of course not
yeah I don't know you said you kind of
touched on this and a few people I've
heard commentary touched on this and it
does feel to me sort of like yeah Tom
Hall is hot right now let's put him in
another property that people are excited
to see especially cuz it's so nice
spider-man homecoming they yell
mentality we got a run Tom Hall and
train for a while people and do you got
a big Tom Hall in an action star now
yeah
that's the thing too is like I feel like
video game movie is still problematic
genre like no video game movie has ever
just nailed it like even the ones people
think are good have asterisk like Silent
Hill and Mortal Kombat link so yeah like
Michael Fassbender and its essence Creed
proved that you can't just bank these on
people that we love because you know you
could still get a bland bad movie so
yeah I don't know there's nothing that
convinces me that this news is gonna
make this movie great I'm now I'm just
thinking well if anything it makes me
less interested in it yeah now is the
trailer is going to have to
win me that much more you know yeah
because like from what little up from
what I know from having played the demo
and like yeah I don't know I was a
little taken aback when I first heard
this I knew enough about the series to
be like huh
I feel like Shawn Levy makes passable
entertainment yes the Real Steel is like
it's cute like it laughs it's a movies
it's like good for what it is but it's
only as much as it is and it doesn't get
any better than when I did the museum
same thing yeah it's like it's fun yeah
so I feel like what we need with video
game movies I mean maybe the bar is set
so low at the point now where we just
need something that that'll get like a
60 percent on Rotten Tomatoes for one
day I mean it maybe that's all we need
right now for a step in the right to
make it really are there we're at the
point where we need a step in the right
direction we need everyone to be safe
maybe not the masterpiece we're all
hoping for but so we thank a 10-year
break yeah we're trying a new one again
before they get you know the The Dark
Knight of video game movies we need that
it's weird because it let you look at
Resident Evil and somehow that series
managed to move the really nice [ __ ] to
and they're rebooting it with some kind
of crazy ambitious link we're going to
make six of the yeah why are you because
like I don't know how well those movies
do but I always feel like they don't get
received very well and they they just
ended the series like I can't imagine
they did tremendous business I mean to
be a little bit more optimistic Tom
Holland is a fantastic actor really is a
fantastic actor and I could see him
bringing sort of that I don't know young
Indiana Jones type of personality to it
or give it the more of a sense of wonder
because you know in who Nathan Drake
part a big aspect of him he's that cool
guy he was always discovering these new
things and on new adventures but when
he's a teenager imagine there's a much
bigger sense of wonder about all these
like explorations that he's going to be
embarking on in this whole new world
this young white kid is a mountain you
know and I feel like Tom Thumb I could
bring whatever aspect that are looking
for there but right now it seems more
like more
getting thing to me than it is honoring
the video game for what it is and I
can't I can't really comment on that too
much as I played like a little bit of
each one of the games I haven't played
one game throughout so what I can tell
you is each time I'd rather watch
someone play when I'm in the room or
play myself Nathan Drake's the coolest
part of it and the one thing we all
wanted was just lets bring Nathan Drake
to the big screen it's like if you
brought Solid Snake from Metal Gear
Solid in and they're like we're gonna do
a teenage version of Solid Snake like
why would we want to
Solid Snake has been cool as an adult
for many days yeah okay and as the thing
is like I feel like a drinks and I'm
charted movie you know whether you start
a drake's fortune or not you know like
that's a good opportunity to fill that
Indiana Jones type void yeah come in
with a new you know like they tried to
have national treasure national
treasures gone away we don't have
they're talking Indiana Jones five who
knows yeah I was going to come together
like this could be a good opportunity to
basically fill that void with something
vaguely different and it just by going
younger again I don't know how much of
this movie is going to be spent on that
if they're getting Tom Holland I got
imagine a good Amell yeah I mean it's
all right it's just not what I currently
want banking I would have had them do
kind of a semi thing of what they do
with it I respect it with what they what
I heard of what they were doing with
Assassin's Creed which is basing in the
same universe and the same rules of
whatever Assassin's Creed entails but
taking a different making a new
character out of it what I would have
liked is okay maybe don't base it off of
one of the specific games but base it
off of Nathan Drake but don't Nathan
Drake and put him on a different
adventure that we didn't see him one of
the video games that you could just play
instead of trying to compact you know
hours worth of gameplay into a two hour
exciting film well I wonder could have
done that instead because I mean I just
don't think anyone care for young Nathan
Drake it as hot as Colin is right now I
it's not an not it's not enough for me
to be excited about this casting yeah
totally and I don't know when it comes
to video game movies to it
is that kind of thing really I don't
know where to put my faith anymore
because we've never really tried to do
one where you just take the story of a
game
aim and transcribe it to a movie and I
can see what it would be kind of
perceived as maybe a waste of time yeah
that story exists in much more detail as
a game yeah but uh yeah I don't I don't
mind this sort of like same universe
different story idea but this is all
especially with this announcement now
that it seems like they're diverting
from what everybody knows uncharted on
now I my anticipation is moving now
rides on that train yeah right real bit
more really does because the thing is
like if they'd cast somebody where I'm
like oh yeah I can totally see Nathan
Drake that would make me excited off the
back yeah and now I'm just like I now
you got to show me moving on guess what
Greg Top Gun 2 is confirmed to be
filming this year or at least within the
year on The Today Show on there i'm
director joseph kosinski of the hit
films Tron Legacy and oblivion -
director of oblivion debated hitch films
and everyone loves oblivion they didn't
think it was contrived and very mixed
reviews and I wasn't one of the few
people who really did I saw flew in
twice an ethereal I really like I really
liked oblivion I thought it was really
good how is this one movie where I'm
like I get your complaints I just still
really liked the experience in this I
feel like a lot of people misunderstood
it wasn't it wasn't um it wasn't a
ripoff film like a lot people putting I
was like this is a Maj piece yeah
totally like it inspired by these other
sci-fi film pieces I totally feels that
way the entire time and I didn't take it
add it's like watching Kill Bill and
going so this is a ripoff janym you know
I wanted to believe it and I was like
yeah I can see a lot of your influences
but at the same time I think you pulled
them all together yeah something that
I'm still compelled by and I still like
the mysteries yeah Eric ters in the
world like that's an example in pretty
cool world building invite in my opinion
and I've seen a couple of videos
especially on a Collider
where they were talking about joseph
agofsky and like why they're not excited
of him doing this film and i don't see
the problem with joseph kosinski I just
don't see the issue with him doing it
sure our legacy is not a great film by
any me on that right
pretty bored when I watch that movie I
thought I'm actually had IMAX camera
scenes and I was doing kinda snoozefest
um at the moment I wanted to see that
living I really like and think the top
gun is not I don't I'm sorry this
offends anyone I would like the ten
people that are gonna watch this video
yeah but toughen not a masterpiece
it is it like it's its beloved for it
being good at what it is but I'm not
like the most tremendous feat it's not
me like she would prove a lot about the
volleyball team like there's some cheat
there's some stuff debated about this is
very tasty super 80s they'sa yeah there
is the bar in San Diego with a neon sign
in their window touting proudly that
they are quote the Sweezey bar from time
yeah she's yes oh man it's like at josh
burger buddy i had it perfect for what
it does like what it is like it's the
perfect pitch for what it is like and
that's why it's so beloved is because
words but i guess my concern if I had a
joseph kosinski concern is is it going
to be fun or Xena take this very serious
because I yeah I might come on at Top
Gun to have some fun with that dominance
then updated like have some fun with it
oh yeah get your gas pump to do the
music for a dictator like sci-fi I don't
need news a gritty antihero
yeah you know I need I need you know
maverick maverick was was you know the
boisterous to sort of like he can't tell
me what to do you know kinda like cocky
and Tom Cruise is producing this and and
Tom Cruise he's been out there saying
that if he does it he wants to do it the
way they did part one which is with
stuntmen in real toilets and he wants to
do the flying and everything again and I
feel like Joseph Kosinski to respect
that enough to not go let's just CGI all
these airplanes you know yeah I feel
like he can work with Tom Chris yeah I'm
interested about Joseph Kosinski because
it's like almost rare that you see a
director go from like crazy science
fiction lots of CG into like ground
yeah and air force like yeah you know
it's both intriguing and also kind of
head-scratching to because in one ward
is you're going to be like yeah
environment and and also you have Tron
Legacy which is like a giant property
movie in the you have oblivion which is
a big sci-fi movie so I don't know much
about Joseph Kosinski voice I guess like
what is what what is he going to bring
to a more real-world scenario because
like even with oblivion of living has
more of that like you know serious toad
yeah like mystery but I get what kind of
movie that is you know so I feel like
Tom for Tom Cruise to choose him for
this I rarely feel like Tom Cruise makes
a misstep and when he is choosing the
directors wonder than Edward Zwick for
Jack Reacher to one and it's like he
works with Christopher McQuarrie all the
time and it seems like he has a working
relationship with Joe kazuya's like he
did Jack Reacher with Christopher
McQuarrie which to me was an OK film had
its moments of greatness but overall was
just an okay movie but then he saw it
you should did the next Mission
Impossible and then became the best
Mission Impossible movie now I think
that I feel like Tom Cruise would know
what he was doing with specifically
seeking out joseph kosinski for this
project Tom Cruise does his weird
quintessence right now we're like in an
odd way I trust his judgement about
these kinds of things I'm like yeah if
you think he's the right guy for Top Gun
- I'm yelps wait to see like I believe
in you and even even lately that some of
that faith is wavered for me cuz I'm
like interesting The Mummy
and although uh what happened with Jack
Reacher to me but uh yeah I don't know
he's not shaken me enough that I'm not
like yes this could work well I don't
feel like he controlled the decision on
the marver who directs that though yeah
I feel like I was one of the few the few
fishbowls he can be in where he does not
have all that the universe is bigger
than himself yeah I feel like he has a
lot to say probably in the mummy but not
all of it and Top Gun - the only like if
you can get it even if Tony Scott was
still around unfortunately he'll not but
if he was still around and he was
directing it the prompters was a minute
we won't care what people give a [ __ ]
most about as tall as Tom Cruise being
in this film as well as Tom Cruise that
they're gonna have most of the control
over what happened to Top Gun to a movie
he did not have control over but now
he'll have control over Top Gun - you
know and it makes sense because that's
that's the mistake a lot of these a lot
of these reboots make is like they're
going they have Tom Cruise they're going
back to make a sequel that's probably
only way more top gun whatever word yeah
because we love Top Gun because of Tom
Cruise you know Val Kilmer's and we
should get fat ass Val Kilmer this yeah
yay eating a burger drinking in and out
shaking as jet pulling off the heels of
Boyle's babbit I was like or did you
work Josh Boone Fault in Our Stars
writer director says x-men New Mutants
will be a full-fledged horror movie set
within the x-men universe the plot for
it is held at a secret facility against
our will five new meetings at the battle
the dangers of their powers as well as
ass into their past they aren't out to
save the world they're just trying to
save themselves and they're all trapped
by heaven from split unbreakable is
coming to the x-men universe it's going
to be good it's fun yeah after we just
talked about Justice League dark and now
hearing about Josh Boone horror movie
director Joss Whedon horse
havoc and now the horrors of developing
powers while also constricted will the
x-men universe out of all these
universes and film franchises they seem
to be the most bold right now but having
cuz Deadpool is technically part of the
x-men universe and I feel like some
people get like [ __ ] about it when you
say that looks like why it is they have
like x-men in the movie they directly go
ahead and [ __ ] with the excellent
universities acknowledge it and yes and
then they had Logan if anything x-men
this within the Deadpool yeah yeah the
way that movie is mechanics work so to
hear that are doing a full-fledged
horror film that sounds office is great
that sounds incredible and and when you
hear horror movie x-men universe you
know these like teenagers who are
discovering these like powers I hear
they have like so I'm concerned it's
like a Wolfman I should have done a
little more research on this before
talking about it because it was more of
the topic of genre full-fledge for that
intriguing that doing a full-fledged
horror in an x-men universe like movie
just makes sense yeah I could see you
doing that and to call it New Mutants
and to not be trying to you know like
Alice's revamp a new x-men team or
something I'm not familiar with the new
mutants as an average moviegoer not an
avid comic book reader to hear that
they'd be doing a full-fledged horror
film that's sounds boldest but yeah it's
a group of one thing none of these comic
book movies have done is that Bowflex or
that's what are these movies do need
like some of the best writing advice I
ever got you know in a specific day I
was like hey you want to write it was
like about Wars like you want regular
yeah well watch consume other thing draw
inspiration at other genres and so you
want to make a good superhero movie now
we know what a superhero movie looks
like bring in in an even bigger way you
know more John runs because I think and
the x-men universe superpowers in
general have so much horror potential
especially just from this blurb here
like there's so much potential for
cruelty just body horror just like when
your body that's what I heard they're
trying to include his body or oh yes
make sense cuz I'm a mutant yeah yeah
it's puberty is scary so like one of my
favorite touches of did that horrible
Fantastic Four movie um that was
directed by was the guy's record that
Josh Trank one of my favorite moment of
that film was when I got like corpse
carry yeah when they all start
discovering their powers and then mr.
Penn
Jasin is miles away so he's like free I
was unsettle yeah I was unsettling it
was creepy and scary and I thought it
was very effective yeah no I was just my
dad before me I wish they had to learn
how scary this might not be you know
yeah exactly I'm just skipping and I
think having this element here a horror
that I feel like that automatically
raises the stakes and I wonder if I have
the idea of having kind of like a
creepier show like Legion in the
excellent universe on FX with somewhat
of an inspiration since that panned out
so well for them to go in a direction of
being like let's try a horror film now I
mean you got your Deadpool which is
insane comedy at the XY universe is meta
comedies you got Logan which is it's
like no argh lennier get it back the
Western yeah and then you have now this
one it's a horror film and to me it's
like this is making me gravitate more to
the x-men universe because all the other
universes of the comic book movies it's
such an element that could be applied
and I'm hoping like Deadpool like Logan
that they go let's make this r-rated one
and x-men at least to me is arguably the
one outside the MCU that has the most
stink flavor the most consistently
because yeah even you know like when
Sony was still making like like amazing
spider-man 2 didn't necessarily earth
take it back amazing spider-man didn't
necessarily achieve those things for me
and you know there are other the DCE you
achieving those things for me and even
though there have been duds among the
x-men films I feel like yeah they do the
most consistently interesting things and
they have a Tambor that hasn't changed
and it feels distinct yeah yeah you know
and they only really lost that Tambor
for me in origins and apocalypse you
know yeah for real
you know even even part three has some
of that so and I think I think this is a
great idea that is it that it's just one
thing that you hear x-men horror yeah
why not I mean these kids are always
anytime easy it has elements of each one
of the films where they're scared the
idea of plays on they are scared of the
people are scared of units and
the mutants are scared of being mutants
they're being hunted and in here some
others are being experimented on yeah
and that just sounds scary and and like
there's their sequences out of each one
of the x-men movies that you could have
turned into horror you edit almost every
one of the x-men tureens whole word is a
horse
all right sort of it is so main scene
the follow us would have been scarier if
they treated more like a horror movie
it's a big blockbuster action film
honestly I feel like that would make
villains more memorable because that
forces us and scary and that forces you
to have tension yeah because even like a
Jessica Jones which is I know it's MCU
show that killgrave had so many horror
elements in it yeah and yeah that makes
it scary yeah yeah and so I'm just
excited to see what they have in store
because I remember the I mean the MCU
cast
I mean it hired Scott Derrickson to do
Doctor Strange I thought it was going to
be their first like scary film
yeah right far from whoa oh yeah yeah he
didn't get to go like hogwash yeah but
but if they're if they stick to the word
happy and having body horror in there
some scary ass films and if you can make
it violent and r-rated then madness is
this is kakouton Logan dead Logan and
Deadpool have been changing the way for
comic book movies to be I feel yeah you
know the MCU really established a very
specific rep but Logan and depth will
have established a very different way to
make movies with it like make movies
into the same universe but yeah the one
thing like the MCU has in common with
most of their films some of them are
like the Captain America comes out a
little bit more serious I thank you the
only time I feel like Marvel has truly
made a film
I feel like Marvel has perfected the art
of making superhero movies and the only
one I felt was a film film was civil war
yeah and I feel like the x-men universe
Winter Soldier - yeah that will get very
it serious it's sort of diverged a line
for sure yeah I think I think Civil War
is the one that nails it's the most
completely but I think x-men does do
that more is like their time it seems
like especially
now is more new phase it seems like they
are interested in making film than not
just movies or what I say fells I'm also
including stuff you know out there like
Legion cuz that's me I'm really out
there yeah well I think because in
cinematic while the EXO universe is huge
because you got so many characters with
it superpower abilities you know like
they don't have to worry so much about
well we got to connect this whole other
different world with this world you know
we got to connect this characters of
this characters so much of the LCS race
is a big thing were they all of the
film's have to complete that's why I
think there's a humor in all the films
because it could they can't that's like
its main connective tone tissue if
that's the best way I could put it one
humor allows you to smooth over the
cracks that come up with yelling over
time so everyone they all come together
and they're all in 20 and it's not weird
yeah yeah yeah might be awkward yeah so
yeah this is this is a good idea I
really like yeah I love you too and the
x-ray I mean the x-men universe is
always lucked out because you know from
the very beginning you just accept that
they're mutants everywhere yeah so like
it's not like you have to bend over
backwards to cross things though yeah
make things work and what about this you
know alright guys well thanks for tuning
in you can catch our full movie news of
the week segment we have a few more
stories that we cover there on patreon
so go check it out over there and become
pretty minted mid or shut that John
Humphrey on Instagram and Twitter social
media manager Blum house calm and click
that notification bell to be informed
when more videos of ours is out and
we're doing a Q&A over at our patreon
page to an exclusive Q&A so go join
there to find out and get a question
answered good night